alright guys bangbang we're back meltem
sear she was the original off-the-chain
guest the very first one in august of
2018 she was so bad that we've kept her
off the podcast but she is here and we
got a whole bunch of stuff to talk about
some crypto stuff some not we already
did the podcast yeah we've been talking
for 45 minutes plan is in the room
making fun of me Joe's over he's got a
new pair of headphones he's ready to go
so nice job
we got a whole studio set up now go to
YouTube I can't say it enough go to
youtube and subscribe
all right enough Schilling never enough
this is crypto pump what what's been up
a year and a half later your chairs now
coin shares alright what do you guys do
what that's a really good question I
only ask hard questions around that's a
really difficult question I don't know
if I can explain what my business does
so coin shares a lot of people know us
as an asset manager and that's really
where our roots started we have a
product line of exchange traded products
in the European market under the brand
equity provider 700 million in assets
under management
so it's pretty sizable platform we have
four products today a Bitcoin tracker
and aetherium tracker ripple tracker in
a light coin tracker our most popular
product is our Bitcoin tracker but what
a lot of people don't know about coin
shares as we do more than just eat EPS
and asset management we are an
institutional finance firm in the
digital asset space focused on creating
products and services to enable
investors to access the crypto market
what does that mean what does that mean
great questions so here's how it breaks
down we have our exchange-traded product
business which is focused on creating
products and making them accessible to
investors our products are different
from some of the others in the market
and that they're created and redeemed on
a daily basis there's no premium on
there and they track the price of the
underlying we also have an advisory
business here in the US under our Broker
Dealer we
also have active strategies where we
invest in different assets I'm
particularly focused on the venture side
right now so we do that through fun
structures and then we also have a
capital markets business we internalize
a lot of our trading a lot of our flow
and now we're looking at different ways
to offer that to the market and we also
have a sizable lending book so we do a
couple of different things in the
process of doing this over the last six
years which is a long time in crypto
we've also built out our own proprietary
tech stack and so what we're looking at
right now is different ways to bring the
technology we've built to manage all the
various components of our asset
management business and our trading
business to the market in new ways into
what is the biggest part of the business
out of all of that because you have a
bunch of different products right but
like what what is give us a sense of
like what's the biggest and down to the
smallest or generally yeah I think the
biggest part of the business the way we
think about it is at the top asset
management drives everything so we are
effectively a customer facing business
and our customer is an investor who
wants to get exposure to digital assets
and digital currencies and then the way
that we monetize that throughout the
business is not only on the management
fees but also internally on all the flow
that goes through our business and what
we're focused on now the newer part of
the business is what I'm building here
in the US which is all of the other
products and services that people want
as they start delving into the
proverbial Bitcoin rabbit hole as people
get down that learning curve they start
to want you know exposure to Direct
Investing
exposure to more sophisticated
strategies more actively managed
strategies and so that's what we've been
focused on over the last year or so
takes a lot of time we're regulated in
seven jurisdictions which is a lot to
manage and as you can probably relate to
being an investor being an asset manager
there's a lot of work that goes into
building the right structure the right
legal footprint the right regulatory
footprint and really building a robust
infrastructure that can support all of
that activity since we talked you went
in front of Congress a bunch of
politicians you kind of did your rounds
in that regulated world what are the
biggest lessons you learned the biggest
takeaways I think takeaway number one
the most important takeaway
nobody understands the difference
between Bitcoin and cryptocurrency
anything else anything else so what I
was and just starting her up but yeah
they use Bitcoin to describe everything
is in my experience is that years - okay
so Congress I have to give a shout-out
to Andy Brown Birgit coin list he was
like I was talking to Representative
Mike Henry's office they're looking for
an expert witness they called me but I
think you're in do really good job so
shout out to Andy for making that
connection my so I got a call on a
Friday afternoon and I had to submit my
testimony like Sunday night right so had
a long time a lot of papers in school
about that's pretty good so it was
actually really interesting about it and
the big plan I also have to give a shout
out to the team at coin Center I had a
few phone calls with them have known
Jerry Robin that whole team for a while
and I think they're really great at what
they do
Niraj give a shout-out to the meme
master he is the meme master for dough
unlike barstool sports which we're gonna
talk about which I'm pretty excited
about but was really interesting as we
were talking about how we wanted to
frame the conversation really what kept
coming to my mind is we need a
differentiate between Bitcoin and
everything else and we really need to
make sure that walking out of that
hearing people understand Bitcoin is
unique and there is no other Bitcoin I
think sometimes when people talk about
digital currencies they say oh ripple
it's just like Bitcoin it's like just no
that's not accurate and so I think that
was an important distinction that was
made but there's a lot of word soup that
gets thrown around and there are a lot
of different people in DC I'm trying to
influence how policymakers think and how
they make decisions and the way they're
describing Bitcoin and other digital
currencies as well as the capabilities
of blockchain technology in a lot of
cases are just not reflective of reality
they're malicious it's hard to ascribe
intention
what other people do I don't think it's
always malicious I think sometimes it's
a matter of incentives ripple is
actually the largest lobbyists in DC
based on amount of funding contributed
which i think is in a way not positive
for the industry right and ripple has
the balance sheet strength to do that
but their focus is going to be very
different they're gonna focus on a very
different narrative than say someone
who's building an open-source software
product that supports Bitcoin and
enables people to self custody and trade
peer-to-peer two very different sets of
incentives so I don't think it's
malicious but people are ultimately
motivated by incentives makes sense as
part of this you got to tell us about
the [ __ ] coin getting into the
Congressional Record because I think
most people now know that it happened
but like was that staged was that was
that pre-planned no so it's so funny
because congressman Davidson was just in
my office two weeks ago and we've been
laughing about that for a while now
so the way it happens when you go to
testify in Congress is you have five
minutes to make a statement you submit
your written testimony ahead of time so
if you go to the House Financial
Services Committee website for every
hearing they'll list out who the
witnesses are they'll link the video
that you can watch on YouTube and then
they'll also have the written testimony
that was submitted you actually also
submit over 100 printed copies of your
testimony to chambers the day before so
I ended up writing I think a twenty page
testimony is there are a lot of boxes
that got delivered to the halls of
Congress the day before the hearing and
then you have five minutes to give a
short kind of opening set of remarks and
then you have questioning from members
from both sides of the aisle and they'll
typically go majority party first so the
highest ranking Democrat will have five
minutes to question then I'll go to the
public and so on and so forth until
nobody has questions people can use that
five minutes to ask questions so the
witnesses or they can use the five
minutes to do whatever pontificate right
and sometimes people stump and support
their own platform we saw that a lot in
the second
they did with Mark Zuckerberg so what
was really interesting so the whole time
in the morning that David Marcus was
testifying congressman Davidson was
sitting there and he had this like funny
kind of smiles smirk on his face
I was like it I don't know what's going
on there but like clearly this person's
very amused and then I'm sitting up
there I do my five minutes fine I'm
getting grilled some hard questions
great handling it and then all of a
sudden he starts down this line of
questioning right he says so in in the
industry people talk about Bitcoin and
then something that is colloquially
referred to as [ __ ] coin I'm like oh and
then he asks he was melted misdemeanors
how could you explain for the members
what is a [ __ ] coin and I was like oh
not gonna talk about that I was like let
me talk about why bitcoin is different
funny um and I think it was it was a
nice way to inject a little bit of humor
into it was actually very serious and I
think a very profound discussion because
the potential implications obviously if
Libra are massive well why he was doing
that Twitter was going wild obviously
and I've actually had him on the podcast
and I would say him and Patrick McHenry
both like they really get it they got it
yeah and I remember before the hearing
goes before the first day Patrick Henry
went on squawk box and Joe Kernan I
threw him just a fastball right down the
middle and it's a really good job on Joe
by the way I'm gonna give you credit for
that one I don't actually don't think I
was the one who could like completely
turned him I definitely I think you know
encouraged him to keep an open mind but
I think some other people got to him ok
because I left one day after recording
and he was like on the edge and then I
came back like a week later and he was
all in and I don't know who that mystery
person that like pushed him I think we
were somebody got there last summer
uh-huh and he was he was already at that
point yeah so like my favorite part
about squawk box is they're they're
pretty serious they do they're you know
regular
in coverage etc funny yeah but like
there's a point last year where I
started to go on and as soon as I would
walk out there Joe and kevin o'leary or
whoever would be there they'll be like
pop like they would get excited like oh
we could talk about this Bitcoin like
this yeah easy because what I just
remember like like it made sense cuz the
incentives we're going back to the whole
idea of incentives like they knew that
those clips would go viral cuz a crypto
Twitter and they were talking about
something and it was also like such a
pure industry from there's some people
who really believe it and some people
who don't believe it at all and like
there's pretty much nobody in but like
nobody's just like I have no opinion
like I there's very few people who think
that about it cause it's kind of like
Tesla yeah as someone who's long Tesla
so is like the only thing that kind of
comes close to crypto Twitter yeah even
close
crypto Twitter is so crazy and so
entertaining it's alright let's talk
about Tesla real quick because there's a
lot of people who were short very
aggressively were yelling and screaming
exception
yeah it's it's real it's real yeah and
there's legitimate questions that they
have that are unanswered I get the whole
thing but I fundamentally always believe
that you can't short one of the greatest
innovators of our time especially when
when you see the car the car is
legitimately better than any other hold
on okay so when people have objections
to Tesla and this is where actually the
narrative about value investing versus
growth investing comes in right and
here's what's interesting so let's start
with quick facts okay month of January
right
yup January 31st three best performing
assets in January 2020 number one Tesla
up 53% number two beyond meat up 33
percent and number three Bitcoin up 28%
okay
Tesla those three are like nightmares
for like half of the finance world right
goes back to so I studied finance and
university and everyone obviously
seminal book Benjamin Graham the value
investor right so there's a large part
of the world stock pickers what they
focus on is fundamental value investing
right so Warren Buffett does and we can
get into his and
and legacy because it's like real if he
didn't beat the S&P for the last 10
years but good well there's a lot time
there's a lot to unpack there but here's
what I think is really interesting
so on the surface if you look at Tesla's
balance sheet their cost of capital
revenues how much they're spending their
indebtedness on the surface right if you
look at it through fundamentals lens EPS
etc all of the metrics people usually
look at doesn't look like a good stock
but here's the thing you have to
appreciate what Tesla represents is a
fundamental innovation just like you
said when you go on squat box and people
run opportune they're like pop Bitcoin
people genuinely get excited about
Bitcoin it sparks something in them that
is like spiritual in nature it's changed
their mind it's a mental shift in how
they think about one same thing with a
Tesla the first time someone gets in a
Tesla you see it in their eyes they're
like oh it's a life changing experience
and what I think is interesting nobody
ever talks about automakers nobody gets
excited about GM or Ford or Volvo or
Honda people get really excited about
Tesla Elon Musk is super interesting
he's very entertaining but more
importantly the whole experience the
whole brand narrative has been
beautifully designed and beautifully
crafted and that sells of course it
sells the thing that I keep going back
to is again you can look at all of the
financials I get that there's a bunch of
issues and challenges etc but at the end
of the day if you are involved in that
business and as an employee an executive
a partner whatever there is something
about this one individual that bends
reality to make it happen okay and this
is actually really important when I so
early stage investing last six years
reality distortion field your job is to
create a reality distortion field it
can't be too detached from reality
that's how you get we work right way to
detach from reality to far out but you
have to distort people's of perception
of reality enough that they believe in
the magic because your job is selling
magic it's selling something that seem
impractical and infeasible and through
force of this reality distortion field
you create around idea the idea the
products the business making it become
real but you're not wrong on anything
you just said
but the one caveat is take we work Jeff
Lewis from bedrock said this on Twitter
another I was just really really kind of
interesting and very kind of
forward-looking he said we all knew what
we work was doing the difference is that
we thought he could pull it off and what
he was highlighting was like the
difference between them actually pulling
that off and getting into the public
markets and probably being okay and
having the meltdown that they had was
maybe the difference of four weeks but I
think there what it boils down to is the
reality distortion field was too strong
there are few decisions that were made a
few weeks prior to the s-1 getting filed
that pushed the distortion too far
that's what he was saying he's like
basically for there's a four week window
that if they had gotten out four weeks
before those things happened they
probably probably are talking about we
work as just another public stock and
nobody ever run the company but this is
why I think early stage investing and
even later stage investing is so
interesting because there is this
intangible quality right you can look at
a business you can look at the total
addressable market you can do really
quantitative analysis right you can look
at all the fundamentals you can look at
recurring revenue run rate everything
you break down margin cost of customer
acquisition share all of the things you
could look at or you could break down
the business on a spreadsheet in an
infinite number of ways and I've done a
lot of M&A works I know all of the tabs
you could create in that spreadsheet but
at the end of the day there's something
you can never capture in a spreadsheet
there's something you can never capture
in any financial analysis and that is
this intangible like magical quality
that captures the zeitgeist of a moment
and Tesla captures that zeitgeist
everyone wants Tony Stark to be real
fact but it's a same thing with tests
are SpaceX as well right like in the
private markets it's been valued much
higher than any other business on a
multiple basis because they can do
something that no one else had never
done like ever usable Rockets brilliant
but also the branding around SpaceX like
the rock
is metallic it looks like the rocket
emoji yeah it's pretty amazing
absolutely alright let's get back to
crypto stuff because we could talk about
Tesla outperforming everyone else's
stocks for a long time that's right you
all have worst performing than Tesla in
January central bank digital currencies
love the other thing though that I
think's really interesting right I want
to talk for a second about value
investing versus growth investing okay
just for a second okay so there's this
entire universe whose incentive right
all these people in the financial order
whose entire incentive is to justify
getting paid two percent or two and
twenty two pick stocks right there
priding themselves and like I have this
amazing capability to analyze based on
fundamentals right this is our world of
value investors now here's the issue if
you're investing based on fundamentals
you would have missed Amazon beautiful
you would have missed all of the
companies that have delivered 98% of SMP
500 market growth over the last twenty
years you would horse it because it
wouldn't have fit into your view of the
world and I think what people forget is
in the universe of stocks you can invest
in over the last twenty years there are
only small handful stocks actually
primarily Apple apples dividends over
the last ten years seven hundred billion
are greater than the combined market cap
of 490 companies in the S&P 500 it's
crazy so I think again people don't look
rationally at the world of value
investing because they're incentivized
that's how they get paid that's the
model that's been the predominant model
in the world of asset management and
then you look at growth investing growth
investing is crapshoot in certain ways
because how do you build a quantitative
model to understand how people capture
magic and how they effectively band
reality so Amazon my favorites and I
usually talk about bitcoins volatility
but Amazon since it went public for 20
years it has drawn down at least double
digits every single year the average
entry or drawdown is over 30% and I
believe that it's drew down 90 plus
percent twice
and so my partner Marquess goalies jokes
he's like who's held Amazon stock since
the IPO like Jeff his mom and his dad
because that's just too much volatility
for most people to wrap their heads
around but also Amazon after they IPO
--d right they went up in price crash
happened
95 percent lost right 7 years to recover
hmm IBM by the way took 17 years over
that same period of time so I think what
a lot of people don't appreciate we
could talk a lot about bubbles but what
a lot of people don't appreciate is a
big part of investing is timing right
same thing people who bought Bitcoin at
the start of 2018 everything in life is
about timing and then it's about
conviction and I think the difference
here is we're making a secular but I'm
not making like a little bit I've lived
through three crypto market cycles I'm
gonna live through hopefully many more
but I think the bet you have to take as
a secular but the whole idea of picking
something that is small before a lot of
people understand it or believe it or
invest it in it and being right and it
grows into something very large is as
old as time right people have done this
with certain stocks they've done in the
private markets they don't know the
Bitcoin they've done with all this kind
of stuff I think the part that people
forget is in that from small to large
you need volatility right the volatility
is what provides that upside but it's
not a straight line and so it's easy to
look back and say you know go out the
10-year 20-year chart on Amazon eBay
chart I have on Amazon oh it went up so
high look at this the 20-year chart on
Amazon is like almost a parabolic curve
it looks like startup projections
exactly and then if you zoom in on those
seven years it just looks like [ __ ] yeah
same thing look you can zoom in on two
or three years of Bitcoin at certain
times right same thing here's the one
thing I will say about Bitcoin though so
so here's the interesting thing and we
can talk a little bit about investing in
alt points because I know this is
something you like talking about so
here's what I think is so interesting
about Bitcoin is you zoom out and it
looks pretty good right like most people
got into Bitcoin 2013 2014
looking an average print entry price of
around 200 $250 we're now sitting at
around $10,000 let's say that's pretty
healthy but the thing that's interesting
is bitcoins not a company mm-hmm bitcoin
is three things its technology in the
form of the protocol it's a network and
it's the entire ecosystem of value
creation that gets built on top of it
which gets internalized in the form of
transaction fees that flow back to the
network and its participants and so I
think what's really interesting about
Bitcoin is people have this limited kind
of view you see this today on Tesla
Twitter right people are like oh it's at
750 it's not gonna go up anymore time to
sell no that's not how ya like this work
right the thing is if Bitcoin does 1/10
of what you and I I think we're aligned
on this with you and I think it will do
then
the upside is massive of course it's um
it's the idea that humans are emotional
humans have very strong recency bias and
so the idea that a Tesla stock was $200
and now it's at 700 how could it
possibly keep going up
well actually the math probability is
that something you know it's like though
it was a law of motion right things in
motion stay in motion companies usually
are like that so you see a company
that's executing and driving revenue and
growing etc it's more likely to stay in
motion than it is to crash right
and I think bitcoins a great example of
this you know networks all this stuff
but that just goes against everything we
know as humans because it's like how
could it possibly go up more than 5x
right how could it go up any more I
think the other thing is people are
conditioned much more by their negative
experiences than their positive
experiences and I suffer from this
myself really I have to force myself on
a regular basis to train my own
emotional state because there are a lot
of ups and downs to navigate in this
market but I do think that people
remember all the bad experiences they've
had particularly I think a lot of people
entered this market at a bad time and
the issue is you know they were buying
maybe ripple at $3 or maybe their friend
told them about telegram and their
family office thought you know big
allocation in the telegram tokens sale
should not just say that that won't be
you know at the end of the day something
worthwhile investing in but it is not
really great experience right now right
two years in there like
not feeling really good so I think there
is this component of people being
conditioned by negative experiences and
forgetting that this has happened before
so many times and it's gonna continue to
happen again so not only were people
buying right if you remember it was like
November 2017 Columbus was signing up a
hundred thousand people a day right so a
bunch of people pouring in near the top
are at the top but also a lot of funds
got started in the second half of 2017
so they were out raising capital and
they were actually raising like pretty
material amounts of capital at that
point so either people were buying
directly or going into the funds the
funds had liquid lockups etc have you
seen one of the things that I was
looking at was like the high watermarks
and causing a lot of funds to shut down
yeah I've seen a couple but actually
haven't seen as many as I thought I
would see like there's still most funds
they've either raised other capital so
that's not subject to those high
watermarks or they've been able to do
something in order to kind of stay alive
what are you seeing there yeah I think
for a lot of funds just generally right
the fund industry is predicated on
two-and-twenty you live on the - you
pray for the 20 so it's keeping funds
alive is that 2% management fee and some
of them may have accelerated fees
particularly if they're subscale sub
hundred million funds and so I think
what you're seeing is a lot of people
who raise at that time maybe they have a
hundred million dollar funds maybe it's
a little bit larger in size so they've
been getting their 2% management fee the
other thing that funds have been doing
is doing illiquid investments so we saw
a lot of funds that combine investing in
liquid assets with investing in illiquid
venture bets and then they were side
pocketing that into a separate side
vehicle that was in subject to the rules
of the fund liquidity profile the two to
three year profile and so I think what
they've done is effectively created two
pools of capital one pool of capital
that can be redeemed in a subject to the
normal terms of the fund and then a
second pool of capital that's much more
longer-term permanent capital and what's
interesting is people have now found a
way to make token investments venture
investments through these things called
shafts or Agreement for future tokens
and so I think again we're starting to
see this blending where people have
realized the reason people like venture
funds and the people the reason people
like permanent capital is
your bet on like an innovative new
technology's not gonna play out in two
years it's not gonna play it on five
years probably not even gonna play out
in ten years because the arc of time is
extremely long and what I always think
about is how many miracles do I need or
how many honest variables am i dependent
on those things outside of my control
and outside of my system and there's a
lot here of course all it takes is a few
things going the right way or conversely
right your point about we work a few
things going the wrong way
that make all of the difference between
a zero and a hero so that brings me to
take Bitcoin for example what are the
most likely reasons why it could fail
Bitcoin I think honestly the biggest
systemic risk to Bitcoin right now is
the centralization of Bitcoin and taking
Bitcoin and shoving it into the existing
banking system and what I've always been
concerned about and I think what we're
starting to see with the rhetoric around
Etan and Bitcoin kind of growing
venezuelan bitcoin growing is the
segregation of the Bitcoin network into
two separate networks one of sort of
white-listed tokens that are fungible
and one of blacklisted tokens that have
such a sanctioned address or an address
that's tied to terrorist organization or
some other sort of axis of evil type of
entity and that creates kind of a
secondary sort of creates a split in the
market so to me the biggest issue is
number one around privacy and data
forensics but I think we're making
progress there's sort of second layer
privacy tools tumblers mixers in
different ways of obfuscating
transaction data and wallet level data
and then I think the second existential
risk is really the risk of custody right
so right now the predominant model for
custody is what we've done with all
assets since the dawn of time you build
a giant fort right if I'm Julius Caesar
and I have all my gold coins I make my
Treasury I take all the coins I put them
in the Treasury and then I have armed
guards you know guard the Treasury and
that's the model we've had for every
asset that's what we do now except
instead of having an armed for we have
server racks and secure locations you
know all about this used to run data
centers right you know all about how
people do this and I think the big issue
here is when you have Bitcoin that's
it's Ana centralized entity and people
start internalizing trades or seem bit
go doing this anchorage announced it's
doing this
what people are trading they're no
longer settling on chain they're moving
zeros and ones between accounts right
you're no longer trading Bitcoin where
you're trading is a Bitcoin depository
receipt and you're removing the very
properties that made Bitcoin valuable in
the first place but can it goes from the
completely decentralized model into the
centralized entities and then over time
be decentralized again but here's the
issue right um
maybe like theoretically it can but
here's the issue once the government has
financial oversight of it and once they
have oversight of Bitcoin and they
realize oh wait 50 percent of Bitcoin is
in custody by entities controlled by a
new idea from the Fed basically what's
their incentive to ever do that there's
zero I just go back to incentives
there's no incentive and so I think what
people don't realize everyone's like oh
yeah you like I'll just put it in
capacity and or like fidelity custody
and then like when I want it back I'll
just take it out I'm like okay but
you're gonna realize five years from now
the requirements for taking your Bitcoin
out of custody are gonna be really
onerous what do you think those will be
who knows but I think the point of
attack like if I wanted to kill Bitcoin
and a limit basically stop people from
using it in any sort of meaningful way
other than a speculative asset which you
can do through synthetic Bitcoin what I
would do is exactly this right I would
say hey if you want to go and climb your
Bitcoin you have to submit a DNA sample
you have to submit all sorts of personal
data you have to wear this location
trackers that we know where you are at
all times you put on a special list so
that when you cross borders we search
you for any hardware wallets you're
gonna be subject to all sorts of rules
and regulations you're gonna put get put
on an IRS list you're probably gonna get
put on some sort of tracking list by the
FBI I just think that again a lot of
people are daxing themselves right now
and they're tying all their personal
financial data and their social security
number to their ownership of Bitcoin on
these regulated platforms and I just
think that that's like yes it's
convenient but those who sacrificed
freedom for security deserve neither
summits so that brings us to the
intersection of crypto currencies we'll
call digital currencies because not
really cryptocurrencies and government
which is the central bank digital
currencies
what the hell's going on there seems
like everyone that's the new thing right
it was like hey everyone let's do
enterprise blockchain now it's like hey
everyone let's do central bank digital
currency all the enterprise blockchain
companies are now doing Central Bank
digital currency because they're like we
need a use case it's like to raise our
series B somebody please give us a use
case ok so my view on this is you
started with Bitcoin which had a small
addressable market and it was sort of a
fringe group of people who are
interested in it then you got a cerium
which brought in a lot of the VCS and
brought in a lot of the developer crowd
then you got the next wave of icos which
brought in the speculative traders but
also the sort of the rest of the
investing crowd right the retail
speculative crowd then you got stable
coins which brought in a whole new crowd
like Wall Street types we're like oh I'm
gonna build the leading platform for
digital tokenized whatever whatever and
then now we're at this final kind of Big
Boss stage which is government saying
hey we're gonna use all the narratives
of all these people before us and we're
gonna make this thing innovation
technology but really it's not
fundamentally that different from the
way currencies managed today and so I
think central bank digital currencies
are part of a long sort of story arc
around crypto currencies to digital
assets and it's completely on the other
side of the spectrum from Bitcoin like
the two could not be further apart so
the polar opposites for sure and so my
whole issue here has been it makes sense
for the incentives of a government to
want to create a digital currency it's
really about access more than anything
right so right now I go to the like the
worst case scenario so I'm a Venezuelan
my currencies being devalued away I
actually want dollars because I trust
the US government I know it's gonna be
more stable than pretty much anything
else I can't get access because I don't
have a bank account if I get dollars
into my bank account I could get seized
taken taxed etc and the black market is
actually pretty dangerous in terms of me
getting dollars and it's also expensive
your big market dollars I like six times
mine yeah so so like I could get dollars
in some cases but it's expensive or it's
dangerous and so now all of a sudden
there's this idea of if I have an
internet connection I don't need a bank
account I can get access to a critical
digital currency right now those digital
currencies are all what we think of
crypto currencies that are listening
like you know koi market cap or
something
but if let's say China is able to go
ahead and digitize their currency before
the US now all of a sudden I can
actually get exposure to the Chinese
currency before the u.s. is currency and
it's literally just because the US
dollar is not digitized versus the
Chinese hold on hold on
this is where I actually disagree with
you okay why the medium doesn't change
the message nobody wants to hold room in
me why is the US dollar the world
currency it's boys because it's trusted
trusted okay so here's where I think
with central bank issued digital
currencies what central bank's suppose
is that if they create this digital
currency and the more important
component is actually the payment system
and coupling identity to digital wallet
that's actually the big push here in
most nations that are implementing this
surveillance right but also being able
to actually implement monetary and
fiscal policy more effectively right
because you no longer have the shadow
economy but at the end of the day when
we think about the reason the dollar is
so prevalent instituted around the world
it's because the medium does not matter
as much as the message so even if I had
access to digital remember or digital
realice or digital you know euros what I
really want is US dollars because what
has liquidity and what has Trust and
what it can exchange with anyone for
anything
is the u.s. so I don't disagree with you
that that's what people want but if they
don't have access then they will start
to use these other currencies and if the
u.s. is far enough behind because
remember the G USD USD see like all of
these regulated dollar back stable coins
they're not gonna go screw around with
the sanction countries right there
they're built in a way where they won't
go into the sanction countries and so
that doesn't work it doesn't work that
way it's the way it works is if you have
dollars all right let's say I have a
million dollars and I go to circle and I
want to create see USD right I give them
my million dollars and they give me a
million dollars worth of see USD tokens
that transaction right there is KY caml
back rule compliant but once I have my
see USD there is nothing that prevents
me from interacting with anyone who has
a compatible wallet to trade CUSD with
that so I don't know about circles but I
think gu
the Gemini's they can friendlies I think
that they can freeze and I wish that
weakest brakes around it to all the
details but they have some ability which
people got all together right tethers
the perfect example tethers built on the
Omni relay protocols so it leverages the
security of the Bitcoin network and now
they have it on ether and Tron basically
every blockchain Network so again the
only point at which you can really
effectively apply regulation is at the
entry point and at the exit point and at
the end of the day what we saw right
everyone's concerned about the
underlying collateralization of tether
and whether the dollar reserves are
actually there turns out nobody cares
like people encrypt our twitter care and
it's sensational and like oh whatever
but when it comes to people who are
functionally using tether to fulfill
this very purpose of gearless nobody
cares because at the end of the day i
tether is a tether is a US dollar and so
people are willing to accept it as
tender so when we go to central bank
digital currencies though I think
there's three things we've to focus on I
just wrote a blog post on this today um
the first is for most countries
introducing a central bank digital
currency is about reducing dollar
dependence and reducing the economy's
dependence on US policy so take for
example a country like Cambodia right
there's just the case study I used here
Cambodia's economies based on the dollar
eighty four percent of transactions in
Cambodia eighty four percent are done in
dollars okay nobody really uses the real
Turkey where I'm from 54 percent of bank
deposits are held in u.s. dollars not 54
percent or to pass us out okay held in
US dollars so again what that means is
all of a sudden the economy becomes
highly susceptible to u.s. monetary
policy so what's interesting is most of
these central bank issued digital
currencies in my view are an attempt to
minimize dependence on the dollar
the second component that really matters
is current account balances so one of
the the important metrics for an economy
to track is its current account right
and the current account is trade balance
of trade so exports minus imports income
from abroad and transfers abroad so if
your net account your current account
pardon is negative your net borrower
from the world and if it's positive
you're a creditor you're a lender to the
world and so what I think is really
interesting here is
out of countries who want to create a
digital currency have a large net
negative account balances there are a
large percentage of their GDP and the
idea here is is that you can start to
actually impact trade policies which are
driven by managing your exchange rate
through this new tool you have and you
can also start to control payments right
so typically starts internal to the
country then you open up your flows
external to the country and so now that
you have a way to manage flows in and
out through this blockchain based
payment system which you control all of
a sudden you have much more ability to
control that balance and then the last
thing which i think is the most
important it's data gathering and
controls right and we should be missed
without block chains as well
the last thing I'll add here is one of
the interesting trends we've had over
the last 50 years really since Bretton
Woods almost seventy years oh my god
the US has been a hegemon politically
economically and also from military
perspective right the US power has an
unparalleled we're now living in an age
where the world is looking a little
different and we're finally in a
prolonged trade war with China which has
been a long time coming
Russia has also started to play Russia
is aligned itself with Iran and other
countries who are energy exporters
Russia recently announced Rosneft which
is the largest oil company in Russia
announced they're just no longer gonna
be denominating any of its contracts in
dollars which i think is an important
trend is we look at the balance of power
in the world they think another thing
central banks have started to realize is
that a great way to reduce US influence
and the ability for the u.s. to be a
hegemon is to challenge US economic
power through the introduction of this
new well and part of it so Russia is a
great example because there's a
conference last year Vladimir Putin was
on stage and obviously speaking Russian
but it and it gets translated but he
literally out publicly said the u.s.
dollar system is super expensive and we
are actively trying to figure out a
different system and he wasn't talking
about Bitcoin or crypto or any of this
stuff right but I think a lot of the
stuff with China and kind of by the way
euro is also expensive because when you
have not negative rates it's like I'm
not sure I want to hold that yeah
the whole and the whole thing just comes
down to the idea that there is a country
that has great ambition but understands
that there's somebody else out there who
holds a lot of power over them and so
one of the ways to weaken that power is
to move off of the US dollar system and
I also think that their identification
of this like it's something they've
always known but the US has actually
been like a that kind of like a good
parent right to some degree of like they
didn't really like go spanked the kids
and so it was always like the threat of
a cat could put you at I matter I will
spank you but then all of a sudden we
started really weaponize the dollar and
the second that we like actually started
spanking the kids are putting them in
timeout never like whoa hold on saying
I'm not playing this game anymore and so
they see other countries that are you
know when there's North Korea Iran
Venezuela etc like they see these
countries being crippled by the power
that the US has and they say look it's
just a matter of time before they come
for me right and so all of a sudden it's
like hey let me break off of this system
and it's almost like the u.s. is power
and maybe not the abuse of our power but
the enforcement of the power has
accelerated the desires of others to get
out of the system and I think what's
interesting here I want to make two
points one is as you start playing out
this chess game in your mind it doesn't
take much to see where the game is
headed right we have all of these
countries who are gonna digitize their
currency and try to use these these
Digital payment rails and digital
wallets to expand their reach to gather
data on people and to get more
granularity and more access to actually
implanting policy at the wallet level
the account level so this is a really
really scary trend and at the end of the
day when you have all these countries
competing with one another to be the
dominant currency you now have companies
who are entering that race because I
think social networks are now more
powerful than most governments I mean
more users more influence Facebook three
billion users WeChat 1.4 billion users
right digital social networks are
becoming payment networks social
networks social media companies
technology companies are going to be the
banks of the future we just don't
I mean look Apple like their surveys
that show that people
Apple Google Facebook way more than a
toaster and then so what's gonna happen
is you have central bank's issuing
digital currencies company is issuing
digital currencies people right how long
is it until the next Jim Jones emergence
and issues is own digital currency or we
have you know the knox sort of cult
leader who knows and so in this world
where there are all these different
competing currencies what we're actually
highlighting is why bitcoins so
important I'm laughing because there's
already some of those cult leaders out
there some would argue who have issued
their own digital currencies but we
won't go there so office of my view like
all the central bank digital currency
stuff all it's doing is beating up the
adoption curve for Bitcoin because it's
the only neutral player here this was my
whole argument behind I think it was q3
last year I went on CNBC and I've spent
two days in Washington I went met with
you know like arsenal stuff and I walked
away and I will get to kind of your
thoughts as to some of these things but
I walked away and I was just like this
is such a different culture and way of
doing business then both the Wall Street
world in you know New York and also the
tech world in San Francisco but it was
like pretty disheartening but also at
the same time like just Shh it just
shook me like I was like wow this is way
different oh well they'll okay so DC New
York's about money
San Francisco is about um social
currency and like controlling the
narrative and DC is about power if
you're into power you eventually end up
in DC and DC is about what I think's
interesting is there's this view in
certain members of our government who
believe that if they want they can snap
their fingers and we'll turn off Bitcoin
they have no idea how technology like
zero concept of how technology works and
what I think's really interesting
anything I mentioned this to you is the
average age of a US congressman or woman
is I think around 70 right I think it's
maybe 72 very representative of the
American population about hold on okay
no nobody is going to go to Washington
in the future and ask for permission
of course and what's interesting is the
government assumes like the US
government takes for granted is
unchecked power and it assumes that it
will always be relevant to the
conversation and I think for the first
time they not have to compete for that
right but part of it yeah part of this
though is we've done this to ourselves
right so what I mean what I mean by that
is there's no term limits right so
that's kind of strike one strike two is
things like I've always thought if you
get elected to an office we should go
look at who your largest donor was and
you're not allowed to regulate that
industry so if speak farmer puts you in
you can't make laws and regulations
around Big Pharma right you know if by
the way it goes that way it's like I
can't make political campaign
contributions to someone and then get
Business Forum barred from doing
business with them for the two years for
whatever yep it completely agrees and
then you know also things like you
shouldn't be able to make a law and then
go get a job that help people navigate
that law I wonder if you're referring to
someone specific there you guys can get
all you want
so there's all these issues right but
ultimately what it comes down to though
is like the rules are in place and we
continue to elect these people and I'd
actually didn't believe this before but
now I'm starting to understand it's not
because they are good at what they do
it's because they understand the game
it's like if you're a startup
entrepreneur and you've never worked in
a big corporation
there's corporate politics game that you
never understand you get eaten alive
because you don't understand the game
same thing in the politics world where
somebody said to me Tobias by the way it
has its own game also for sure yeah
absolutely
but but it's just the people are
actually better at the process than they
are getting results right and some of it
is they don't want to get results in
certain situations because that keeps
them in office look I think it's what I
think's interesting right is we're in an
election year right now who's gonna win
it doesn't matter okay no no and here's
why they're all the same that's true
okay but different okay Democrat
Republican don't care who you are what
you say well Donald Trump used to be a
Democrat and now ran isn't a Republican
and Mike Bloomberg used to be a
Republican I believe and now a Democrat
in the US right people like to believe
that there are differences between the
two political parties there aren't
they're one in the same what I always go
back to like the world we're living in
now what I think is so terrifying
everyone who's into crypto I presume
loves an R and so an ran in the fountain
how there's great speech called
Francisco's money speech where this
character Francesco talks about you know
the way that man escaped the jungle is
through capitalism through the promise
of enterprise like lifting yourself up
out of the cycle of poverty through
enterprise and making money and we
celebrate money in our society and we
celebrate people accruing money because
it's a sign of like it encourages people
to innovate it's what drives people to
do and accomplish and achieve and when
you get to a point where people who do
nothing start to demand that they have
the right to take money from people who
have amassed it that's when the system
starts to break down and you look at the
rhetoric in DC right now both sides of
the aisle
that's the rhetoric everyone wants a
bigger share of what's being produced
and what we get for it is nothing
because the amount of grifton insider
dealing that goes on is preposterous
because only two areas in our economy
where there's inflation is education and
health care so much various but but it
it shouldn't be surprising to us right
so two things that I tweeted recently
that I fundamentally believe one was
around bait Bezos just had 120 billion
in net worth every was freaking out
about it and I said look by the way my
favorite is that basis made a raid ollio
and 15 minutes of these amazing if you
confiscate all 120 billion dollars from
basis right however you do that whether
it's do taxes are legit like just give
us your money we have guns right that
doesn't solve any of our problems
because it's not a money problem in many
cases a systemic issue and so like
confiscating money isn't gonna solve it
because what you would be doing in that
case is you'd be taking money from one
of the greatest capital allocators in
history and giving it to one of the most
inefficient capital allocators but it's
not about do
anything with the money this is about a
gotten like DC is about power
Oh agree it's about the fact that I can
go to you and threaten this and that you
respond to that right it's about control
and again I think a lot of the problems
we have are really complicated complex
problems that have their roots and a lot
of different issues Bitcoin is not a
panacea blockchains are not a panacea
there is no magic bullet that solves
these problems right all we can do is
try to understand the causes of these
problems look at the facts of the
situation and try to use both public
policy and by the way I'm competition in
private markets to try to improve how we
handle these issues that's it my other
favorite is I've never seen a politician
pledge to give away 99% of their wealth
there's quite a few rich people who have
done that in the giving pledge I've
never seen a politician say I'll give
away majority of my wealth instead what
they say is how give away a majority of
yours and that's easy to do of course
that's easy to do when all your
responding to is trying to get a byline
into Fox News but look I think at the
end of the day what I'm excited about
for the first time right we have more
women in Congress than ever right we
have more age diversity in Congress than
ever we have more diversity just across
the spectrum in Congress than ever
before it has gotten better would you
say it has gotten like it again in terms
of we're on the right trajectory terms
of diversity etc or you disagree with
that I think when people talk about
diversity right its diversity of
perspective and diversity of skill set
they used to be only wealthy people were
in the ruling class right for eons and
eons that's how society was governed was
wealthy elites who controlled the money
controlled the power also made the rules
and that worked right then well didn't
work it worked for those people right
and they had the money in the guns and
all the fun things then we started to
get into the era of career politicians
and political dynasties and again it was
still you came from the moneyed class
and like if you came from a wealthy
well-to-do family you're a member of
parliament in the UK and then in the
u.s. though he did that is people from
wealthy established families ran for
office and they became senators and so
on and so forth
now what we're seeing for the first time
is the democratization of politics and
when I think so interesting Donald
Trump's a divisive person obviously in a
lot of ways one thing that Donald Trump
has proven to me I don't I think it's
very unlikely that we will have a career
politician as president ever again you
know who I think is gonna win president
one day
and people get real mad at me who the
rock Oh
Dwayne the rock Johnson is my number one
pick for president polina's in the room
she's laughing because she tells
everyone that I think the rocks may be
President one day and here's my logic
incredibly charismatic so likable the
most recognized actor globally yeah he
there's a bunch of studies that show
physical size has a lot to do with who
win so he put on debate stages etc yeah
he's huge he's massive like yeah and
here's the best part is Trump won like
Scott Adams has dissected this to the
point of like The Dude's just an expert
at this but but he basically says he's
got this weapons-grade persuasion and
what Trump was able to do was every time
you backed him into a corner he was able
to use humor or attacks to finagle his
way out make people kind of chuckle and
move on right the other thing Trump did
is he was upfront about the fact that he
was an [ __ ] yeah of course if you
just own it there's a bunch of other
people who say you know what I'd be one
too if I was a billionaire right like
that whole mentality but imagine Trump
and the rock onstage in a debate and
Trump says something to Dwayne Johnson
like a jab at him and Dwayne Johnson
just goes ha ha ha such a candy-ass up
and you could just see the route like
it's over like it's done because he's
more physically intimidating he's
actually probably more reasonable he's a
very rational bikable also I think he's
very person look I don't disagree with
you there
I am like somewhat excited and somewhat
intimidated by the era I think the other
big shift that needs to happen and this
is a shift that needs to happen broadly
um it would be interesting to see how it
gets navigated is a lot of people don't
realize the roots of Silicon Valley stem
in needs of government
right so a lot of pardon I said of
course market also yeah right MIT where
I'm to grad school biggest donors
funders of research at MIT DARPA and DOD
right and so there's a really strong tie
between our government and innovation
Amazon's about to become the largest
contractor to the US government right
for cloud computing services look at
that and so in mind no wonder they want
to take all of his money impossible by
the way just as a swarm Buffett and Mark
Zuckerberg between the three of them
have more wealth than 50 percent of
Americans
you're like an interesting statistic
great but you also a harness again you
don't believe that anyone over the age
of 55 should vote what's up with that
okay
I said this in the pre-show how do you
got that I hope you hope I forgot okay
here's my view right okay so here we are
we are living right now in the year 2020
and about 30% of the labor force is set
to retire in the next 10 years pensions
are underfunded by an average of 25%
meaning they only have 75% of the
liabilities that you need to mean and
then they're underperforming what they
need to keep growing yeah because their
their growth rate was 7% which is like
okay that sounds unfeasible thanks very
very good and the way they invest by the
way which is super low risk doesn't work
preservation of principle is not gonna
save you and so what I think is really
interesting right we've all these people
retiring um and what's what's concerning
to me is people who have time and money
in this country are people who are
retired right so they turn up just
proportionately to vote they drop the
vote and also all of the people who are
in office are of that older generation
of that might on average yeah yeah and I
think mine sets the really important
component here like they share the same
mental model they share the same
influences that shaped their thinking
right and how they view the world and so
you have these people who are the large
donors with all the money because they
have all the assets right and then you
have all these people who are in an
office [ __ ] of that same generation of
that same mindset and they're making
rules and policies I'm in my mid-30s
right I'm going to have to spend the
next 30 years of my life working and
paying taxes to cover
health care shortfall the social
security shortfall the pension shortfall
all of these things that this population
is gonna need I should get to decide who
makes decisions for me did you get to
decide cuz I'm gonna be liable for those
decisions not these people who are
retired and who are going to be enjoying
the last 20 30 years so here's I should
get to decide because I'm gonna be the
person who's liable for producing the
assets to make up that shortfall my
money is the money that gets devalued my
future is being sold to finance the
present for a generation of people who
have already benefited a lot from this
system so what you're talking about was
very well highlighted I saw a chart
recently that showed the average age of
fortune 500 CEOs and basically for the
last 15 years it has continued to
increase and immediately people said
that's not because all of a sudden we
started like moving up the age it's
because the same people been running the
fortune 500 companies for the last 15
years and so they started when they were
45 then when they were 50 55 60 etc and
it's just they all just kept moving
around in between the different
companies but there was one kind of
cohort of people who have continued to
run the largest corporations in America
the same exact thing in politics right
Chuck Schumer's a great example he's
been in politics for I don't know how
long but it's not two years same a
different and by the way the way that
politicians make their money we should
look everyone has to make a living and I
don't knock people for this it's knowing
the game but the game for politicians
like Bernie Sanders right he didn't make
his money by having a job multi
multi-millionaire he's a
multi-millionaire he made his money
through consulting contracts through
speaking arranged like again same same
same but different there is very little
difference between politicians people
who run corporations and people who run
large investment firms it's like the
same set of incentives the same set of
goals and it's the same people do I
don't care what you personally who you
think should win in terms of like your
politics but looking at it from a
rational seat who do you think it's the
Democratic nomination well that's a
really good question I think Bernie
probably will you think so you think
this is the time he gets it
I don't know but I feel like a lot of
people right now like rising wealth
inequality growth of 1099 gig worker
miss like that whole economy I think
there is enough anger around wealth
inequality that's someone like Bernie
will get the nomination I think you
better shot than he's ever had who do
you thinks gonna get it but also doesn't
matter cuz Trump's gonna win
I think yeah I don't think is gonna be
close I thought for like two seconds
that it would be interesting to see Mike
Bloomberg vers Trump and then Trump
absolutely like so here's my whole thing
with with politics today and this isn't
a Trump thing it's just in general and
I'll pick somebody from each side of the
aisle that's very good at it so Trump on
the Republican side a OC on the
Democratic side she's fantastic at this
as well yeah they understand that it's
not about the message it's all about the
delivery yeah right and so Trump beat
Bloomberg the second he tweeted out mini
Mike it was over which also by the way
goes back to what we were just talking
about career politicians done this is
about and by the way tying it all back
to Bitcoin this is Bitcoin strength
Bitcoin isn't just an asset right um how
many people actually wake up every
morning and are excited about a stock or
a bond or the FX they trade or the
commodity they trade like literally
nobody right except for Tesla and even
that I think is just yeah money is free
and so when you have free money you have
to dump it into something so like fake
me great like Tesla great their thirst
up a bit but Bitcoin what you're getting
at is the idea of Bitcoin is a
separation of state and money no Bitcoin
more than anything else is a social
movement it is a set of ideals it's an
identity
same thing with politics the people who
are gonna win political elections are
people who move and inspire and create
emotion mmm right and the way you create
emotion in the world we live in is by
having a really strong message that
resonates with people okay mom's message
resonates with people I don't agree with
all of it but it definitely resonates
with a large percentage of the
population in this country
same thing with Bitcoin bitcoins message
resonates with Millennials yeah well
yours we're setting
I always just throw it in the bucket of
separation of state and money because
that social movement that's basically
like the end result right but what
you're saying is the movement they're
like almost the process is really really
important
before we go deep deep down the rabbit
hole of politics I have other questions
by the way my views on politics are not
that informed I just think it's very
interesting that in America people
believe there are two different
political parties I'm like they're
saying the same yeah yeah but and the
reason why polenta is lat actually she
laughs she gets mad at me for for
talking about politics all time from
America to no place from Bulgaria
I'm Turkish all of Europe is corrupt
just like America news newsflash every
government is corrupt but my point in
saying all this is I look at the
political stuff through the lens of like
the marketing in the messaging and it's
fascinating to me to see and I guess I
got like trumpet AOC literally are the
same person and that they understand how
to deliver a message through certain and
their primary channel is Twitter of
course which i think is really
interesting because though they get to
speak directly to people they completely
have cut out the middleman of the
journalistic like mainstream media who
they know were twisting their words to
fit a narrative now if they can talk
directly to the people you you get what
happened last night we're recording this
the day after Superbowl Trump tweeted
after the Superbowl and say
congratulations to the people of Kansas
even though Kansas City is in Missouri
so like you get mistakes but you also to
talk directly to people but here's
what's the best about that is Donald
Trump literally doesn't care no he
deleted the tweet and literally kept
going it's on brand for him it's so on
brand of course of course he'll just say
the haters are just trying to bring me
down and he'll keep going that's the
whole thing is the the idea of having
the tough skin right is it's something
that I think people who grew up in a
certain time period where social media
was very prevalent right these younger
people they're used to having to have
tough skin because you're having a
conversation out in public and so like
my father
imagine getting attacked on every day
like he people encrypted Twitter get
attacked
he can't fathom that but by the way this
is what's so fun about the crypto
community is people judge things on the
merit of your ideas in most cases right
there's like a lot of people out there
that are a little cray-cray but most
times you're judged on the merit of your
ideas like I could call that all the
time and then people get to change my
mind and I'm like oh yeah you're right
like I was wrong about that and I think
that's the beauty of it that's the
beauty of having social media is you get
to have conversations on the internet
with strangers
yeah Twitter is the WWE I've talked
about this a million times it's like
there's the villain the hero the tag
team partners whatever thing another WWE
type entity is barstool sports
by the way shoutout to my partner who
works at barstool sports it's his
birthday today so shout-out to him
little love on the podcast if I can't in
Pompeii can cover your podcast we may be
dachshund now he said to me in melton
don't ever don't ever tell crypto people
who I am like people know him and yeah
he's like I don't want to go to crypto
things I don't talk to people and by the
way I feel the same way about the
Barstow people so we both belong to cult
they're all coming together they're all
2021 barstool and crypto we're all gonna
come together it's gonna happen
well barstool is now gambling company
which is pretty exciting but look you
and I were talking about this in our
prepaid cast the exclusive pre podcasts
that we should record the pre pre
podcast and then just release it go
ahead the pre podcast yeah and then we
can do pre podcast no no you're sounding
like Justin son and all right alright so
what about barstool sports okay so we're
talking about the way that ideas spread
mm-hmm and I think I joke with my
partner all the time I tell them you
sell memes on the internet for and then
you corrected me you said they make
memes first and then they seldom memes
right and so I think there's this
interesting thing where we're living in
this age where the the the cultural
zeitgeist is really important like a
look at their eyes of tick tock look at
their eyes of memes look at these things
that go
viral there's like this esse mural kind
of quality to the way we interact in the
way we participate and what I thinks so
interesting about barstool by the way
one of the biggest most popular media
companies in the world they're like
outranking ESPN and they're a bunch of
jabroni x' and like misfits from boston
yep who talk about all sorts of weird
stuff if you've ever watched any of
their content it's very weird it's very
off-color yeah frightfully I don't know
what I should have done some beginning
for those that are no Barstow Sports is
a media company started out in Boston
2003 the founder Dave Portnoy literally
was making the free newspapers that you
would hand out and he'd sell advertising
in them he discovered the internet
decided well I'm time to make in the
newspaper sitting outside handing it out
when I make a blog then all of a sudden
it became this Skype video yeah the
rooms Skype video calls which by the way
on my fourth date I was first to watch
one I was like I don't understand
billion dollars because he recently so
first he sold half the business to churn
in then he took some more investment and
then the big news was recently they have
sold a third of the business to Penn
national which is a publicly traded very
large gambling company and kind of
infrastructure yeah because he knows etc
and barstool is basically gonna be the
sports book in these casinos and if you
think about it
what's really crazy about barstool so
one of the things you and I were talking
about is they decided so they cover
sports and then they decided to create
their own sport it's called rough and
rowdy I have the privilege of watching
rough and rowdy because my partner
manages a lot of the streaming platform
and the subscriptions twenty five
thousand people buy this coverage rates
like fifteen to twenty five pop I think
and the numbers go anywhere from
twenty-five to fifty thousand they've
done like seven or eight of them it is
literally amateur boxing it's amateur
boxing but it's it's so politically
incorrect it's you know they had one of
their team members who is publicly out
as being gay fight someone in Florida
like box against this person someone who
went to jail for like a homophobia and
like crimes against yep I get her so
right so like they pit these people
against each other
it's just it's so off-color it's like
taking the sport of boxing and
overlaying it with like what Vince
McMahon did with WWF right and add in
bum fights I don't know if anyone ever
got Comedy Central like bum fights that
also is a throwback oh I liked the like
but what they've done and they've done a
very good job and they added in the man
show if you remember Adam Carolla at the
man show they have the girls and yeah
yeah so the one thing that barstool does
I'm gonna draw a line here between a
number of different things in society
that people don't think are connected
but are highly connected barstool sports
Kylie Jenner the rock and tick tock
stars okay right and those four are all
connected because they do the same exact
thing they build massive loyal rabid fan
bases for whatever their thing is and
then they turn around and they start
advertising the word that either they
are the advertisement or the advertiser
product and then all of a sudden they
rose why am i advertising somebody
else's product I mean I should just sell
my own exactly so barstools done that
very well Kylie Jenner obviously has
done that very well the rock is coming
out with his tequila what's the product
I'm a huge believer in this model we
will see uh to be completely honest I
don't know yeah well cause it's hard to
sell financial products well it one is
financial products but I actually am not
even interested in doing that as much as
like I think that there's a lot of other
things that are much more interesting
and so to me like the financial products
are you there's a slippery slope between
like legit financial products and then
like the latest financial guru type you
know well yeah we all saw I SEOs and the
best of the best got pulled into that
yeah and just like like that's just I
don't know that's a world like I don't
really like and don't want to go there
etc
instead it's I think a lot about in
finance there's a lot of things that
haven't been done that have been done in
almost every single other industry so
everything from physical products to
merchandise to you know works of bands
like celebrities have historically been
no offense like crusty white dudes yeah
and they all saw the same thing what are
they selling they're selling their
advice every single time they sell
advice
but also over there fund yeah exactly
but the world of finance I think change
like fin twits really fun major
shout-out to I think downtown Josh Brown
and Michael batt Nick we're both RIT's
Holt they do a great job in sort of
blending viral social media Howard Linz
and built stock twits so we know we
can't give Howard Linz in any credit why
because he's gonna listen to this and
then his ego is gonna get even bigger I
love you Howard okay Howard you have to
buy me a drink next time you're in New
York but he's done a fantastic job yes
but I think there are people who started
to eat away at this but I think this is
what's really exciting this is where it
comes back full circle so we've seen a
lot of innovation the internet drove a
massive amount of innovation and the way
drove innovation is it made creating
distributing product really easy right
so the cost to bring your product to
market whether it's an app or some sort
of service went down drastically as we
started to see things like
infrastructure as a service right
through cloud we started to see software
as a service so you could now have
access to MongoDB and then you had
marketing as a service with things like
MailChimp then you had API is that
connected all of these different things
to social media and all of these other
services and all of a sudden the cost of
building an audience is virtually zero
right you built an audience basically
with zero investment just time yeah time
exactly and so what we've seen in that
arena we're starting to see now in my
view like web block chains are doing
what the Bitcoin network is going to do
is enable this to happen in finance
mm-hmm absolutely and I think finance is
this area of their life that like
everyone has such a weird relationship
with money and this is something that's
really interesting to me is when you
talk to people about money how much
money you make what you spend your money
on your budget how you invest it's a
topic that no one likes to talk about
I'm pulling up at we right now keep
going but this is the most important
thing in our lives like money and the
decisions we make around money and the
education we have around money is the
one of the most important things in our
lives and we don't teach it to people
which i think is a huge mistake but
there is such a fundamental like
component of money and finance that
people need to understand so we need to
number one drastically reduce the cost
of bringing financial products and
services
market make them look and feel seamless
deliver them through by the way and this
amazing supercomputer that's in our
pocket and then more importantly we need
to make it interesting and fun and
socially acceptable for people to talk
about money I don't understand why
people aren't talking about it so the
tweet that I'm trying to pull the online
makes it okay for you to talk about
money by the way it's just like pretty
amazing of course that look the the
tweak that I'm trying to pull up right
now which hope that I can find quickly
is I tweeted the secrets that the rich
people don't want you to know and it was
literally I use secrets I used that very
specifically because what I wanted to do
was I wanted to highlight the fact that
nobody likes to talk about money
everyone is super nervous of talking
about it and these are like really
simple like financial advice things hold
on let me see if I can find it real
quick so you might have to edit at
something out for the first time all
this time has taken me to find this damn
sweet okay so I'll just talk while you
browse okay I'm just gonna riff okay but
I think what's what's exciting here um
and it actually ties back to Bitcoin
right and it's actually also ties back
to politics cuz all of these things fit
together in such a beautiful way what's
really interesting as as financial
innovation starts to creep into
different parts of the stack as people
look at new distribution models that are
focused on leveraging the strengths of
social media and these other platforms
or people are congregating what starts
to happen like we're already seeing this
with Bitcoin how do you regulate an
asset that has no real physical
jurisdiction and so what's gonna start
to happen is historically finance been
one of the most regulated industries and
for good reason we're gonna start to see
is an evolution of how finance gets
regulated because it's gonna be
impossible to manage the proliferation
of all the ways in which people are
delivering financial services and
products already we see this of course
already we see this and so my hope is is
that as this trend continues and
accelerates right that it'll lead to
significant reform both structural
market structure reform banking reform
but also a financial regulation reform
because there is so much that we need to
do better like let's be very clear
people talk all the time about having a
registered offering or people
like oh you know our ICO is like a reg D
regulated offering or IC o---- is like a
reggae like by the way that doesn't mean
[ __ ] having expensive lawyers file
paperwork for you does not confer
quality the law the lawyers one in the
IC o---- craze the lawyers the people
who made the most money in all of crypto
on average is lawyers and by the way
stos
not interesting to me why because
there's negative selection bias people
are using us TOS to raise money
typically raising money in that manner
cuz they can't raise it in another way
and by the way distorting that's true
just because again it goes back to
investing most socks do not perform well
do not perform at all being publicly
listed doesn't confer quality on a
company right there's small handful of
companies that deliver all the stock
market return and so a lot of people are
like oh if we make the capital structure
more innovative and flexible and allow
anyone to buy securities particularly
high risk early-stage securities it's
gonna have this amazing boom affection
it's like know most of those investments
are still not going to perform well
because they're high risk investments
doesn't mean people shouldn't make them
but I think people confuse the cause and
the effect and so I do think it's
important that you know the regulation
component doesn't actually do anything
other than increase the barrier to entry
that is literally the only impact of
regulation is increasing the barrier
time so my whole thing with a lot of you
call them stos I think of it more as
automated finance right and the reason
is a digital Security's yeah it well the
reason why I use automation automated
finance is you need the asset itself to
be digitized
but kind of so let me throw something at
you let's see what you think about this
I don't think I've ever said this
publicly my whole fascination with
what's going on outside of Bitcoin is
one simple idea pre 1400s there was a
single entry accounting and that single
entry accounting was basically very
narrative driven so it would say you
know meltem gave me six chickens I owe
her eggs every day for a year right and
we'd have to literally read the words to
understand it was all Roman numerals
were used as well so it's really hard to
do addition subtraction etc Egyptians
use strings not tied in them which all
kinds yeah okay and so in the 1400s
right before the fourteen
it's basically two things happen that
we're really important when printing
press was invented and two we went from
Roman numerals to more of Arabic numbers
those became more popularized but in the
1400s there's this guy possio Lowe or
something like that
paci oli I think if I get it right he's
known as the father of accounting and
what he realized he was writing a book
on mathematics and when he's writing
this book it was about all kinds of
different men mathematics including how
art was related to math all kind of
stuff and he included a section on
something called double entry accounting
and he learned this from some Italian
merchants with the merchants wanted to
do was they couldn't figure out what
they owed people and who owed them what
so he created two entries debits and
credits he saw by the way this was the
start of Venetian merchant banking so he
saw it put it in the book one of the
first people to read the book Leonardo
da Vinci
because Leonardo da Vinci was reading
why he's paying the Sistine Chapel about
the art and math yeah also happen to
read the double-entry system he was well
known at the time he began telling
people about it one of the people he
told it Medici bank the Medicis that
owned the bank awesome they start
getting everyone to use it and bam here
you go you're off to the races so this
guy becomes now known as the father of
accounting but at the time nobody knew
is all in our da Vinci
well that one thing in the 1400s today
is the foundation for every single
transaction that anyone does right and
so it was if you think of it as a
technology accounting as technology is
probably one of the most important
technology inventions in a very very
long allowed for the the rapid
proliferation of lending absolutely
service one of the largest explosions
was in the United States with the rise
of corporations as businesses investing
also you had it rip
in 1989 there's a Japanese researcher
who came with triple entry accounting
yep nobody cared 2005 cryptographers
said what about that triple entry
accounting and digital receipts nobody
cared 2009 first real world application
of this triple entry accounting system
all sudden hundred fifty hundred sixty
billion dollar asset with Bitcoin if my
theory is correct
triple entry accounting will be the most
important invention technology wise in
our lifetime and no one's talking about
it I think people are talking about it
they just don't use that language yeah
they talk about it as stos or
blockchains or all this other stuff
Tamizh
the way I describe it is the flattening
of the finance stack okay what does that
mean okay so basically what that means
it's something that's on you that went
to MIT would say so what does that mean
I think it also is like somebody who has
booked a trade right okay the way it
works right there's three layers to how
transactions work
there's the execution which is you and I
agree to something we shake hands and
we're like okay that's the trade then
there's clearing which is you and I
providing instructions and then our
respective compliance departments
confirming it joong-ki caml and then
there's settlement which is the actual
fund swapping right so what's really
innovative about blockchains in my view
and bitcoin network is you've collapsed
all of that into one single ledger so
instead of those things happening in
three different layers and in three
different places a lot of extra work you
can now do these things more efficiently
on a single settlement Network which is
why the way what makes stable coins so
interesting is for the first time
instead of having different
interoperating networks that don't
connect to one another having to
reconcile and do double-entry accounting
to track what's flowing where and manage
it all you can have all of this stuff
happen programmatically on one ledger so
I don't disagree with you at all the
other framework that I use that I go
after the technology folks who don't
understand the finance world is if you
look at humans we're all networked or
we're all nodes in a network right and
we used to be very siloed and fragmented
so I couldn't talk to you you couldn't
talk to me unless we wrote a letter to
each other that was slow or we were in
physical prime I might have a carrier
pigeon girl actually wrote me a love
letter one time her eyes just lit up
like do not tell that but I'll tell her
I don't think eyes lit up was there more
like what listen I could share a little
bit of fake news on the podcast she did
you ever do the words on the fridge
where you could spell out no no no no no
she liked like let's be in stride it
wasn't it loved those instructions but
going back to my story this idea that
humans are all super fragmented yeah a
sudden we added in connectivity by
giving internet mobile phones etc when
you connected all of those humans at a
networked productivity exploded all
right ok now go to the
Nantz world everyone's balanced yeah of
course but then you have the finance
world all of our balance sheets are
siloed so I have a balance sheet I can
settle that with debits and credits you
can settle yours but they don't talk to
each other the second that you had
triple entry accounting red or black
chains etc into it
now sudden you're connecting balance
sheets all around the world through this
centralized ledger or third party ledger
I believe that that will lead to a
massive explosion in productivity well
we don't know yet is what are the first
applications other than Bitcoin that
kind of take off with that issue there
though is again it goes back to
incentives one of the big challenges is
right now your average bank or financial
institution thirty to forty percent of
the people they're working compliance
and work in legal so they're the people
who are doing the clearing in the
settling or what we call MIT and back
office right and so I think the hard
part is and this is by the way like I'm
working on a big series around FinTech
and the five areas or I think we'll see
disintermediation first which I think
will be fun to talk about that I think
we're we're we're we're gonna see it is
in places where there's a lot of
resistance to removing those functions
there's a lot of what I call tribal
organizational knowledge because a lot
of times when you go into financial
institution God knows I've been around
my fair share anytime you try to change
your process people first use policy
then use regulation then use compliance
and then it's this is the way we've
always done things and because this is
finance we're not gonna change it so I
think this is where the path dependence
thing becomes really interesting so you
made a comment earlier about needing a
lot of force to change the trajectory of
something right and so right now we're
on this course where the world of
finance is on a certain path right and I
believe in path determinism that once
something is already on a path and it's
in motion it has velocity it has
acceleration potentially because the
mass keeps growing and growing and by
the way after the 2008 financial crisis
all of the policy changes that were made
made that mass continue to grow right
it's picking up speed because it's
getting bigger and clunkier and heavier
and uglier and Messier for banks in the
United States control over 50 percent of
consumer deposits all right
consolidations the only thing that's
happened so this is getting bigger and
faster speeding up so to kick this thing
out of its trajectory which is eventual
like massive implosion you need
something with a tremendous amount of
force and the thing that has a
tremendous amount of force is
thing that is so disruptive that it
changes everything and it has to do it
kind of in like a one-shot moment so I
think there's all this gradual stuff
that will happen that will start to seep
into and start building competence
within large financial institutions
Billy have you ever watched a bank try
to build a website no but I can't
imagine that it's very efficient it
looks like AOL 1996 right and so I think
what's gonna happen and this is where I
think the urgency is gonna come from is
tech companies are gonna come become
financial institutions and in a very
rapid span of time banks are going to
see all of their market power eroded all
of it and so they're going to have to be
they're going to be forced to do
something really drastic right it's kind
of like what's happening with the
central bank narrative something's gonna
happen there that's gonna kick off this
massive sort of wave don't know what it
is but a broken clock only has to be
right twice a day that's right all right
before we switch topics the tweet I
found it what rich people don't want you
to know number one you won't get rich
off of salary alone to inflation steals
your wealth so invest three buy assets
not liabilities four never spend more
than you make five pay yourself first
always six compound interest works
wonders now none of those things are
groundbreaking ideas they're very well
understood in people who understand
finance etc the thing about this tweet
that shocked me one it went viral and
two the number of people that reached
out to me and said I want to change my
situation yeah and what shocked me was
how few people talk about money but it's
blew me away but here's what's really
interesting even when people do talk
about money go to a bank website go to
an asset managers website it's not fun
it's not engaging right yeah it's boring
it's really boring
of course because that's all they know
and they've been scared out of their
minds by regulators in compliance oh I
have this conversation with my
compliance team every day it's like
don't tell me no tell me how I can do
what I want to do but I do think like
there are all of these forces that are
coming together to shape what I think
will be a really exciting time I think
the last decade was all about SAS
software as a service and
this next decade is all about delivering
financial services financial products
through digital first experiences and
tech companies becoming financial
institutions that's a great segue last
topic but they're actually two that are
related Zero Hedge and coronavirus let's
talk first about coronavirus then we'll
get into the Zero Hedge nonsense or
controversy what I'd love to say about
coronavirus what I want to know is what
is your view on the response that
certain entities and organizations have
had so I'll give you three of them what
is the Chinese government appears to be
taking it very seriously I've seen a lot
of videos where everything from today I
saw a drone that was going floor by four
and an apartment building outside and
taking the temperature of people so that
a human didn't have to get close
yesterday I saw a photo of police had
surrounded a building where somebody had
been found with the coronavirus to keep
people out and then they've constructed
the thousand bed hospital in like five
days or whatever right it's like pretty
aggressive response and you've got US
public or private companies like the
airlines who are saying we're cancelling
all flights all this kind of stuff and
then the US government today or
yesterday I think they announced that
they're going to actually prevent any
Chinese nationals from traveling to the
United States oh I didn't know that
happened today I was expecting that to
happen sooner I'm shocked it took so
long I think so alright so what do you
think about those and all confirmed that
that's true global contagion of every
kind is a boon for people who want less
cross pollination immigration so I think
one of the biggest observations are on
coronavirus is the amount of racist
rhetoric that has entered the
conversation which i think is not
surprising given the day and age we live
in but I find it deeply disturbing I
think one of the other pieces to
understand here is on the stark sort of
differences in how the u.s. treats
things how China treats things just
different perspectives around the world
seeing the the speed of the response in
China and seeing how seriously they're
taking this and how willing they are to
go to those legs I think is very
eye-opening the
in the u.s. like we can't do anything
effectively I think you and I in our pre
podcast which next time well Joe we
should secretly record them when people
come in Oakland it just killed that idea
that's how decisions get made around
here I got wild ideas and Joe and Joe
looks at me like oh that's a great idea
and then when it kills it that happens
at least five times a day all right keep
going okay but I think what's really
interesting right is looking at for
example that video of how quickly the
hospital in Wuhan was built some of the
examples you just highlighted I think
what's really interesting is the way
that the Chinese government is using
technology to really really speed up
efficiency and the way they react to
this in the US if I tried to build a
hospital it would take like a year just
to decide that we were gonna build the
hospital if the if the CDC we're going
to issue any sort of statement it would
take like six months to even agree as to
what the statement would say as I think
again like their pros and cons the
situation but I think in an epidemic
situation like this it's really
interesting to see how to Tahlia terian
control and the idea of empire and
single unified voice that all responds
to direct leadership from the top is
sometimes more effective than our
bipartisan system or like literally a
politician would use this as a way to
stump for some campaign issues like what
people are dying so I think that's just
an interesting thing to note the last
thing I still about coronavirus is all
like all scripts are Twitter been crazy
they're like oh crew norovirus drives
Bitcoin you know I drove that coin is a
bunch of central bankers getting
together in Davos talking about digital
currencies literally every hedge fund
manager in the world was there picked up
their phones called people in they're
like I need Bitcoin did you see the
picture of the ECB governors when they
got together at dinner this is a this
goes to your point about the regulators
aged late and all the stuff there's a
photo that a Christine Lagarde I think
shared online and she's like me and all
the ECB governors and it's literally 24
people who all easily have to be over
the age of 60 years old they all I've
had white you know etc and when you look
at it I call it MPs
what's that male palce tell me maybe
that's a little bit offensive like the
MPs cushion in those conversations all
right so under these directives non-us
citizens who have been in China within
14 days of their planned travel will
be permitted to fly to the United States
that's what it so it's not Chinese
nationals it's any non-us citizen who
has been in China within 14 days that
actually makes sense to me so I think
the biggest issue here is like stopping
contagion we had the first case of human
to human transmission of corona virus on
US soil I think on Thursday someone in
my office was sick on Thursday I was
like do not he was like I'll come in in
the afternoon I was like stay home Marty
Stenson if you are feeling unwell go
home stay 11 of the 19,700 cases of the
new corona virus are in the u.s. all
right so that brings me to 0 virus like
interesting we'll see how it unfolds
health pandemics are always scary yep um
and we are definitely not equipped to
deal with these no but I think this is a
new world we live in right which goes
back to like hegemony and power I think
the next great frontier is going to be
the digital realm right like the biggest
area of spend for governments in the
future will be cyber security you think
about the impact coronavirus has had on
mobility think for a minute if systems
went down yeah the first 195 Americans
that were evacuated from Wuhan which is
the epicenter of the outbreak are under
federal quarantine will remain at a
military base in southern California
until mid-february the government hasn't
issued such a quarantine order in more
than 50 years according to CBS News
I mean look global pandemic terrifying
all right so that gets to zero heads
which I will caveat this entire
conversation with I don't want you and I
to get into zero heads good or bad or
should they have done what they've done
I think that there's a much larger
conversation but also it's irrelevant
yeah fair point right spective Zero
Hedge are irrelevant yeah there's a
bigger competition around censorship and
deep platforming right and so what Zero
Hedge essentially did for those I don't
know it's a they are described as a
financial markets blog some people would
argue that they're more of a highly
radical conservative outlet that is
sharing everything from like real news
to kind of extreme ideas to conspiracy
theories etc I would I would describe
Zero Hedge as a post apocalyptic
Nantz website yes it's like a dystopian
post-apocalyptic take on all things
finance interspersed with like really
weird scammy financial advisors writing
articles about really esoteric really
thinly traded stocks absolutely yeah so
they wrote this article and the headline
was essentially is this the Chinese
scientist who's responsible for
coronavirus and what they said in it
they strung together a whole bunch of
what are confirmed facts but they strung
it together in a very controversial way
and what they said is look in Wuhan
there's this university that university
has a Wuhan Institute of biology and
there's this professor that professor
has been studying SARS and coronavirus
and how they're carried in bats and
other animals and transmitted etc and
they pulled up his profile the
university's description of that work
their past publications open job
applications etc and then at the end of
the article they said oh by the way if
we want to know about the corona virus
maybe we should go find out from this
guy here's his email here's his phone
number so that happened last Wednesday
BuzzFeed said there's a guy Ryan
Broderick who said yeah that's not cool
he wrote an article that said meet the
pro-trump you know alt right or whatever
blog that has Doc's the Chinese
scientist whom is inaccurately accused
of releasing the corona viruses like a
bioweapon well well let's check mark
portrayed as I like to call it
absolutely so long story short Zero
Hedge gets banned from Twitter
permanently banned for according to
Twitter violating their manipulation
policy whatever that ends up being and
so the internet goes to work and the
Internet is undefeated in these
situations they with literally within an
hour I saw people tweeting about the
reporter his tweets from 2012 it tails
into 30 and I'm not gonna go into the
details of them but they fall into two
categories one there was some comments
in and around pedophilia which obviously
immediately you know people get very
uncomfortable about and complaining
about and then too and rightfully so and
then too
he also participated in the daxing of a
business owner in 2013 basically shared
information where people were doxygen
somebody and so as you get into this it
all comes down to Twitter you know I
wrote this morning that they D
platformed somebody for quote-unquote
daxing a Chinese scientist but they only
really gave publicly available
information in the blog but that was
reported by a BuzzFeed reporter who
previously had Doc's somebody else and
some are allowed to say some are using
facts and facts don't matter ok explain
ok that's very trumpian I'm just very
realistic yeah two facts have never
mattered by the way a great book to read
for people who are interested in this is
a book by Bernays it's called propaganda
written in the 1930s Bernays advised the
tobacco industry on how to effectively
create propaganda he also and a less
sort of you know how do I say less sort
of politically acceptable turn of events
he also advised the Nazi Party on how to
effectively implement their propaganda
campaign but it's really interesting
because what it's really about is facts
our objective and subjective right
there's also a great book on how
statistics can help you be totally wrong
about everything which is basically how
you can manipulate data to basically
tell any story you want but what I
think's interesting here is like what
you're talking about is facts of the
situation right yep at the end of the
day a platform like Twitter what they're
responding to the what is the goal of
the Twitter Corporation what is their
only function in life as a corporation
to maximize Sherriff yeah so their
obligations to their shareholders any
sort of negative media event any sort of
negative press event any events that
cast them in a negative light has to be
handled and dealt with right and this is
where d platforming comes in and what I
think so interesting this is again like
we live in a country fortunately where
we have freedom of speech that's a right
that's protected by Bill of Rights and
that is a right that when it's infringed
upon gets to take us taken to the
highest court in this country the
Supreme Court to be deliberated upon and
then these precedents are set that
established people's right to free
speech
right this is why code is considered
free speech by the way which is amazing
thing what I
really interesting here is Twitter
theoretically is a privately owned
corporation your access to Twitter is
bound by Terms of Service that are on
Twitter's website right there at the
bottom of the site Lee Steph no one
reads in Twitter's Terms of Service they
basically get to dictate when and how
and where they can remove you from the
platform and the real question here is
does Twitter have any obligation to
maintain free speech what's your answer
well as someone who invests in companies
right and as someone who understands how
corporations work my responses Twitter
is a privately owned company and his
only obligation is to its management and
its shareholders that's why so one
correction I get we're saying publicly
traded company but privately in the
sense of it's not a public utility owned
by the government exactly right and
there's a difference between a public
utility and there's difference between
privately owned corporation Twitter at
the end of the day is privately owned
corporation privately run Corporation
and the only people who get to decide
what happens to privately run business
and privately owned business people who
own it and in this instance there are
majority shareholders who happen to be
you know some of the executives of the
business and then they're a bunch of
other smaller shareholders who really
have no voice who happened to be the
stockholders right unless there's an
activist investor who's accrued a large
share but at the end of the day the only
obligation of Twitter management is to
shareholders and there are only
responsibilities maximizing shareholder
value that's historically how firms have
worked right now the other side of this
conversation though is a more important
question which is what is the function
of Twitter as a platform is it a utility
that anyone who follows the First
Amendment should have access to
what do you think I'm split on the
debate I spent a lot of time talking to
Andrew torva the CEO and founder of gab
in fact we had a great conversation
about D platforming at crypto Springs in
September with Jim Patterson the CEO of
ease the marijuana delivery company and
Cindy Gallup who runs a social-media sex
platform called make love not porn where
people upload user-generated porn
basically and we talked a lot about deep
platforming Andrews response he's built
a platform that basically enforces the
the First Amendment right so it protects
people's right to free speech in the
Terms of Service R if you do anything
that violates the Constitution then we
will remove you from the platform but
otherwise we're gonna protect free
speech and he's been D platform from
every service as a result because a lot
of the people that gravitate towards the
platform are people who've been D
platformed on both sides of the aisle so
he implemented mastodons to decentralize
the network and its infrastructure so
that he doesn't run all of the servers
anyone can run a server in the network
so if his servers go down because his
his infrastructure providers stopped
servicing him which happens to people
all the time network won't go down he's
used Bitcoin for the payment side of
things to allow people to pay for their
memberships he's built his own mailing
infrastructure so I think there's that
approach but the hard part is Twitter is
where the volume is right if this were
market Twitter is where the liquidity is
we're gonna click starts where the likes
are so I think the big question here is
it's the same question we have with
Facebook right three billion users on
the Facebook platform
it's the biggest social media utility in
the world
does Facebook have an obligation to
anyone other than its shareholders well
it basically it's the same argument of
like could the telephone company refused
giving you telephone service if it
doesn't like what you're talking about
on the phone well with the repealing of
net neutrality the answer is yes but
this has always been the question right
is what is the line between private
enterprise and public utility and this
is part of the challenge when you have
such a large percentage of the
population on networks that are owned by
private companies right
same thing with let's talk about Jeff
does this right Amazon we all use Amazon
every day right what if Anna's
decides that doesn't like Eunice's pomp
you can't use Amazon you've no recourse
same thing with uber same thing with
Google right so I think again there's a
really fundamental question about what
happens to these platforms that become
so large that they become the utility
but do you think that there's a
difference between Cody Cody platforming
somebody from services versus from the
conversation from like speech related so
the same thing you think so yeah Twitter
is a service know what I mean by service
is like if Jeff Bezos says hey you can't
get your packages delivered through
prime anymore because I don't like you
like you're kicked out of prime to me is
different than Twitter saying you can no
longer be part of the conversation how's
that you have no speech
because once speech related and one is
not yeah but there are plenty of social
media platforms that you can go to
instead of Twitter Twitter doesn't owe
you anything
of course my whole by the way I don't
actually think that Twitter should be so
two things one is I don't think that
Twitter wants to be in this situation
like jack has been pretty clear like he
doesn't like being in this position he
doesn't want to be in this position
that's why they're working on blue sky
yeah but this is the age we live in we
live in the age of outrage right okay so
if you look at polybius the polybius was
a philosopher who lived in the time of
Aristotle and polybius observed an
interesting pattern in how humans
organize themselves right and this has
been the issue since the dawn of time
typically the way we start is there is a
monarch great like a strong character
who unifies everyone under him or her
but mostly him unfortunately throughout
history maybe we'll change that plane oh
let's start our own monarchy sorry Tom
are you on board okay so you get the
model I don't have a [ __ ] pillow on
my couch right now this is benevolent
dictator and it isn't talking about me
he's a gift and somehow the gift has
persisted you have unifies everyone then
leadership passes on to their children
their children's children and over time
like the strength of that leadership in
that lineage fades and then all the
wealthy merchants start getting angry
right and they're like wait a minute why
is this person why is this family taking
advantage of the situation where the
people actually run the country so then
they put themselves in power overthrow
the monarchy and then they
past leadership to their children it
becomes an oligarchy right and then
people get upset about that the next
layer down overthrow them they're like
wait a minute we're the people we should
have the right to representation then
you have democracy and then the phase
that comes after democracy is something
called o´clock receipt which is what I
think the world we live in now it's
ruled by mob
so it's whoever shouts the loudest is
who gets heard by the way Trump and IOC
and like everything we've talked about
is basically for democracy yeah and then
all of a sudden like the mobs get so
loud the yelling gets so loud everyone's
fighting with everyone balkanization on
all fronts
everything splinters and you end up with
total anarchy and then you just repeat
the cycle do you think we get to the
total anarchy in our lifetime I think so
I mean look I think that we are at a
point if you look at what's happening
around the world yellow vests in France
Hong Kong Venezuela if you look at what
happening and Etan like we assassinated
a world leader who the u.s. who do we
assassinate an Iranian general right
hold on we got to go here so here's my
whole thing on this situation hold on
let me finish those okay good okay so if
we look around the world at what's
happening right even the election of
Trump right I think increasingly what
we're seeing is people no longer respond
to logic or fact they respond to how
they feel social media and the way we
consume information
Russian Russian factions spent $100,000
on Facebook Ads
best ROI per dollar spent ever because
they shaped the narrative of a nation
for the next four years and probably
another four years and so what we're
seeing like the great war that's being
fought is the war for our minds and is
how we feel and it's how we what we
believe in what we think and not based
in facts people are attacking and
hijacking our own psychology and using
our own brain psychology against us so
in my view like anarchy is inevitable
because when there are enough factions
competing for control over your mind the
ultimate result is chaos do you think
that sorry I sound like a crazy person
no you don't are you you used to wear a
suit and go to corporate finance
sessions and do budgets so I wanted to I
want to talk about
sulemani rule because ideas are pervy
so sulemani is an Iranian general he's
basically the second most powerful
person in Iran for for most intents and
purposes and we killed him when you say
we let's be very specific the United
States Armed Services comes in yes yes
and when the United Sates killed him I
saw a whole bunch of narratives online
but the two most powerful ones that took
hold were one hey we just created world
war 3 and we just kept like the
vice-president of Iran essentially and
game on this is gonna be really bad the
other narrative was we just killed a
terrorist right
and those two what's crazy
they're both rooted in fact ok but hold
on but here's the question right what
provocation was made that resulted in
that action so I had the caveat with I
spent time in Iraq for a year and thank
you for your service not in that sense
but in the sense of the information that
was fed to Americans was came from two
sources those that supported the
decision and those that did those that
didn't came very harsh in the we just
killed this this is really bad I can't
believe we made that decision etc it is
undeniable this was a bad dude right
bad dude in the sense I mean I think
it's ironic because we made such a big
deal out of the NBS Jamal Khashoggi
thing and even though the situation is
very different I think it just feels
similar in some ways and I think it goes
back to again you know is the function
of the US like what my tax dollars are
being spent on while I do you believe
that protecting human rights and sort of
helping maintain peace is important
function the function really belongs to
the United Nations not the United States
exclusively and what I take concern with
is we are living in a world where like
the Millennial population is massively
indebted we can't be retirement
obligations or there's a retire
debt crisis that's coming and what we're
investing in is starting wars we can't
ever possibly leave in that actually
we're winning doesn't mean anything
right like if you look at a rock look
what would winning mean oh we should
have left but when a ten years ago 20
years ago so winning didn't have a
meaning right wait no but here's the
thing is that we got very so two things
one it's very well understood now that
the American people were lied to
without a doubt undeniable etc and then
two is I mean literally on the ground
there was days where we're just looking
around like what the [ __ ] are we doing
here right and part of that was there
were certain things that occurred that
looking back were very positive in the
sense of Saddam Hussein being removed
you know all this kind of stuff but past
a certain point it went from we are
taking out a bad dude
to we are now gonna rebuild a country
and I don't think that you can
fundamentally rebuild a country to begin
with but also that's not the job of the
United States and this is where it goes
back to like okay thanks for a great
economy though the petrodollar
very strong but I think the hard part is
this right we have decisions being made
by people about going to war they're
being made by people who've never served
in the armed services whose children
have never served in the armed services
and so what I take issue with is we have
a country that is running on a massive
budget deficit we are spending trillions
of dollars of capital on wars that are
really ideological war is more than
anything else right well because budgets
don't matter because we just print more
okay i'm mt i know that's the like topic
du jour but when we stop being able to
export our inflation through our
monetary policy that's gonna change
oh i don't by the way i don't think it's
good but that's just the world we live
in right where we're literally the debt
doesn't matter like it's just just keep
increasing the ceiling just keep
printing more money whatever and it's
just accelerating the world that I think
you and I both agree Berger we're headed
so the last thing I and I actually think
epsilon theory aka Ben hunt captured
this really well on a blog he wrote
about like there are only really a
handful of outcomes
here and based on what a thing happens
it's gonna be very different things for
what you should be investing it he
describes three kind of outcomes one is
the zombification of everything which is
basically like a Japan like situation
where everything gets gutted out like no
inflation ever again
no growth ever again like just zombies
yeah then there's the great jihad which
is where the world like just goes
haywire we have that anarchy situation I
talked about chaos and then it's guns a
Bitcoin and gold like gonna chip off
little flakes of gold to buy Carolina I
know a lot of people who've been
prepping for that one for a while I'm
not endorsing any of these views by the
way I just I think it's an interesting
way to view the world and then the last
one is we just continue accelerating as
is and there's some sort of great debt
snowfall and then everything gets wiped
clean we start over I don't know which
of these are likely but I do think one
of the things I have to recognize at
some point is like is this sustainable
and I think the answer is fundamentally
this is not sustainable yeah
and so the question is is like isn't
gonna happen in my lifetime I don't know
I think probably because my lifetime is
gonna be much longer than the lifetime
of the generation before me right I
think longevity is another area where
very interesting to think about in the
context of retirement and sort of assets
as well but I think we are on the
precipice like all of these different
challenges in our world are compounding
into really dangerous mix and all of a
sudden we're giving people weapons of
mass destruction in the form of social
media and tools that literally
manipulate your mind I'm gonna end with
something that I think a lot about which
is what's saying the pen is mightier
than the sword yes well we are starting
to realize is that a tweet can change
the course of history and I we we pretty
much saw that with the sulemani stuff we
dropped a bomb right or many bombs and
we kill a lot of people and there was
military action but at the end of the
day Trump's tweets both
accelerated the situation in a negative
manner right causing more conflict but
at the same time I believe that he
probably actually got the Iranians to
back off a little bit when he came over
the top kind of like this mob mentality
of like if you do something then we are
going to do something so much worse and
I don't know what that means for the
world but it's something we've never
seen before well worth of mutually
assured destruction
having thought before I mean this is the
whole conflict of the Cold War it's
essentially a massive game of chicken
which is by the way the game we're
playing with China by the way also the
game we're playing with Bitcoin right at
the end of the day you have to know what
game am I am I playing
and what's the end goal it's out and
outcome and then how do the rules of the
game change as I play the game and
that's a great tweet the central banks
will blink the central banks will blink
first 100% that's my belief all right
where can people find you on the
Internet
we've only talked for almost two hours
oh where do they find you on the
internet Twitter
primarily alright what's your handle at
melt underscored um okay well coin
chairs uh corn chairs Co coin chairs Co
coin chairs Co is our twitter handle and
then coin chairs Co is our website we
have a lot of groups coin chairs comm
don't want to talk about it but we have
a lot of great whoever has it I'll buy
it from you so I can mark it up good
that's happened a lot of times by the
way on handshake to lunch today so I'm
gonna own the quenchers Co h four knots
domains so you know pretty soon we're
gonna have immutable domain names what
about uh unstoppable domains I've looked
at unstoppable domains I have you bought
a domain yet I have oh all right this
episodes launching on a Monday they're
the sponsor so that was a great right
unstoppable domains we love you and I
think the the last thing I'll end on is
um please read our research and give us
feedback on what you want to see and let
me know what contents interesting we're
always putting out interesting research
interesting analysis I'm the person who
likes to make the charts so give me a
shout join shares long Bitcoin long
barstool sports long everything that we
like here alright guys thanks so much
for listening